is there a rapper as multi-talented as
Missy Elliott in 2019 Missy Elliott
became only the third rapper to be
inducted into the songwriters Hall of
Fame besides her own chart Toppers she's
written for Alia Mariah Carey and
Beyonce in 2019 she was honored with the
video Vanguard award at the VMAs for her
Legacy of culture shifting music videos
let's not forget Missy Elliott the
dancer while some rappers are still in
their performances she's leading the
dance line from the front
it's Missy Elliott's originality and
diverse talents that have made her so
influential on a new generation of
rappers you can especially see the Missy
influence in artists like Tiara whack
whose original flow and mind-bending
music videos have earned her critical
Acclaim in 2015 Tierra whack tweeted
Missy Elliott is my biggest influence to
which Missy responded much love to you
Tierra whack I'm happy to be your
biggest influence makes me proud
following you